So another important thing that you can do with this representation
is recover the joint distribution. Remember a couple, a couple slides ago
we looked at the issue of how can we go from
the distrib, joint distribution to specifying
what the probabilities are, the conditional
probability tables, they're called, at each of these nodes. But we
can actually go the other direction as well. We can go from,
from the values in these conditional probabilities tables in each of
the nodes, to computing the probability
of any combination, any joint combination
of variables that we want. So, it turns out it's really, really
simple. We can just go and use these same ideas and say
the joint probability for some assignment to the variables, is equal to
just the product of all the individual values. So the probability that that
value of A would be taken times the probability that that value
of B would be taken times the probability that that value of
C would be taken, conditioned on those are the values that were
chosen for A and B. So it's just like in the sampling case.
>> Right, and
that's much more compact a representation.
>> That's a good observation, yeah. So how, if
these were Boolean variables, how many values would we
need to specify for the joint distribution in the
standard representation, where you just assign probability to everything.
>> Well if I ignore the fact that there are some constraints that we might be
able to take advantage of, it would be
2 to the 5th, because there are five variables.
>> Right, but here we've broken it down
into smaller chunks so, the probability of A,
it's just specified by single number. Probability of B is
specified by a single number. Probability of C is specified
for a single number for each combination of A and
B. That's four of them. This also requires four values and
this requires four values. So this is really, what, it's
like 2 to the 5th minus 1 I guess. Because, if
I tell you the first 31 values, the last, the
32th value, it's just 1 minus the sum of the other.
This is 14 numbers versus 31. You are right, it is more compact, 31 is bigger.
>> Right but let's imagine that all of the
variables were in fact completely independent of one another,
then you would have 5, you would only need
5 numbers. It would be the product of the unconditionals.
>> Yeah, which is what we'd get if we had kind of like just a
set of weighted coins. If they're unrelated to
each other, but each one has some probability
of coming up heads, the probability of getting some, some particular
combination like, A is heads and B is tails and C
is heads and D is heads and E is heads. We
could just break that down to the probability of the individual events.
>> So then all of the, just like with the joint distribution where
you have this exponential growth, because you need to know everything. Here you
have the exponential growth that only depends upon the number of parents you
have. If you have no parents, then it is constant, if you have parents,
then is grows exponentially with the number of parents.
>> Right, so the fewer number of parents,
the more compact the distribution ends up being.